I mean you had a movie star's dad yeah
it's no secret yeah I mean I look my dad
was he wasn't you're you're a calm no
like a normal actor guy you know he was
really good at everything he was an
amazing athlete he was good on a
motorcycle he was a cowboy you know what
I mean to me he wasn't like an actor he
was just somebody who was really tough
really handsome really smart girls liked
him he was good at everything like
that's got to be hard for you as a kid
my dad is everything how am I going to
inspired it no I mean I think it made me
wanna do be good at stuff I felt like I
got to grow up with someone who had a
lot of amazing qualities to look up to
and now as I get older the qualities
that weren't worth looking up to were
also a lesson you know what I mean he
was like that was gonna be my question
right yeah he's a he was like a he he
was like watching a hero's tale and a
cautionary tale at the same time and
getting the best out of both